Ich werde jetzt am draus diesen Wunder, wenn man mit einem Schwatten glättet.
Habe ich ihm auch gesagt, irgendwann ist es soweit, irgendwann passiert es.
So ist es jetzt, ne? Warte mal, was ist denn da hinten?
Weisst du? Ich sehe das auch.
Warte mal, ach du Scheiße, das kommt so. Was ist denn?
Was ist denn? Oh, ach der Steil steigt jetzt aber nicht.
Steigt dieses Brotallerei! Stefan Tietze, der Spaßroboter aus der Zukunft, fliegt auf seinem Elektroskateboard durch die Gegend wie ein Flug und die Leute in der Stadt haben nicht die leiseste Vermutung, was da durch die Strassen fegt und drehen den Kopf um wie ein Uhu. Stefan dreht auf Schallgeschwindigkeit an seinem Drehknauf, seine leicht gebeugte Haltung auf dem Skateboard sieht gequert aus.
Manchmal fällt er runter, aber sicher ist, er steht auf, denn das Skateboard war zwar teuer, doch auf keinen Fall ein Fehlkauf. Hey, vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro an Caveman. Wir haben Caveman, Cobra und Cripple X, die haben auch schon das zweite Mal den Platz als Intro gewonnen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, dazu Fantastisches Intro natürlich. Schön, dass es jetzt schon langsam auch in den Bereich der Fanfiction geht. Also, dass die Podcastgeschichte weitergeschrieben wird von Stefan, der Zukunftsroboter. Finde ich auch mal gut. Also, schreibt gerne mal eure Geschichte, was wäre, wenn wir mit Folge 160 aufgehört hätten, wie ging es dann weiter, was macht Stefan heute, was mache ich heute? Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, wir sind doch hier nur unter uns, oder? Ist nicht so, dass jetzt neue Zuhörer mehr kommen. Ich glaube auch nicht. Und wenn ja, dann werden die doch verschreckt. Also der Podcast dreht sich seit 80 Folgen nur noch um sich selbst. Die Intros kommentieren sich selber, teilweise kommentieren sie andere bereits dagewesene Intros. Wir kommentieren alles nur aus Folgen, die schon alle... Wir erzählen noch, haben wir gerade noch in dem Vorgespräch, es gibt ja immer ein ausruferndes Vorgespräch. Siebeneinhalb Stunden in dieses Vorgespräch. Ja, in diesem Vorgespräch. Da haben wir auch gesagt, wahrscheinlich, wir können uns an die ersten Folgen noch nicht mehr erinnern. Auch an Folge 200 kann ich mich noch nicht mehr erinnern. Null. Heißt, wahrscheinlich erzählen wir seit ein paar Folgen komplett Dinge, die schon mal erzählt haben. Was dazu führt, glaube ich, dass neue Hörer komplett irritiert abschalten werden und dann lieber sich ein Audible-Exclusive-Abo abschliessen, um so viel Passmann und Markierst Kalle zum Beispiel zu hören. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro und ich bin gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Ich glaube, es engt sich auch immer ein, die Leute, die die Intros machen. Irgendwann haben wir dann nur noch so zwei Leute, die abwechselnd die Intros machen. Finde ich aber auch toll. So ein Komponistenstreit. Komponisten-Darwinismus quasi. Ja, ja, finde ich gut. Wer die, ne, gut. Wo es dann nur noch so zwei in der Stadt gibt, wo man sagt, okay, du bist auf der Gruppe der Caveman Cobra oder du bist halt bei Philipp, bei oder die beiden trennen sich. Daniel drei. Daniel drei. Oder die beiden trennen sich und machen untereinander so Disc-Sharks gegeneinander. Oh, das ist ja immer schwierig. Auch dafür würden wir eine Plattform bieten natürlich. Ja. Selbstverständlich. Hallo erstmal und herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Folge von Das Podcast Ufo. Das ist mittlerweile die 219. Folge. Glaubst du, wir trennen uns irgendwann und dann macht jeder... Selbstverständlich. Also du machst einen Solo-Podcast und ich versuche irgendwie bei Gäste Liste Gasserbahn reinzukommen, so als Schlagzeugagzeuger, der nur die rudimentären Sachen kann, aber irgendwie selber nichts aufbauen kann. Ich würde wahnsinnig gerne mal einen Talk-Podcast machen, wo ich regelmäßig Gäste habe, mit denen ich spreche, vielleicht sogar mehrere, das würde ich gerne machen. Mehrere Gäste auf einmal? Auf alle Fälle ohne dich. Das ist das Konzept. Das ist die einzige, also wenn ihr da draußen irgendwie Werbeträräger seid, also Katja machte für Gallery Voice, ich würde auch für alles andere Werbung. Das reichst du so bei Spotify, Konzept ohne Florentin. Hauptsache ohne Florentin habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gehabt. So alle anderen Sachen kenne ich noch nicht, darum geht es mehr und mehr. Nicht aus Antibetik gegenüber dir, ich meine, 219 Folgen mit dir sprechen ja ein klares Zeichen, wie sehr ich dich mag.
Aber irgendwann reicht, also nicht, dass es reicht mit uns, dass wir auf jeden Fall weitermachen, aber ich hätte gerne so ein Zeitprojekt nochmal. Wie ist das eigentlich? Muss man seinem Podcastpartner sagen, wenn man in einem anderen Podcast ist? Also ist es ein Affront, wenn man es nicht macht? Ich mag das ja nicht, das höre ich häufig bei Podcast-Partnern, dass sie dann sagen, du moderierst ja den Podcast und dann wird dann nur noch in meinem Podcast in der Singular Form gesprochen. Das mag ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also wenn du jetzt eingeladen wirst irgendwo und du sprichst die ganze Zeit von deinem Podcast, finde ich es schwierig. Ich glaube auch mein Podcast wäre ein anderer Podcast, wenn ich den mit jemand anderem aufzeichnen würde. Du würdest das anders aufziehen, oder was? Also wenn das unter deiner Flagge... Es wäre konzeptionellisch exakt das gleiche. Ich würde natürlich auch nicht mehr Zeit in ein Konzept investieren oder in aufwendige Einspieler. Beine überschränkt, leerer Blick, das ist alles noch gleich. Das ist alles noch gleich. Ich würde halt nur... Die Anwesend eines anderen macht ja aber auch automatisch ein anderes Gespräch daraus, wie du ja weisst. Ich glaube, ich bin auch zu jedem Menschen ein bisschen anders. Also ich glaube, ich rede mit keinem Menschen gleich. Und ich bin auch vielleicht mit manchen Menschen nicht so wie mit dir lustig und man spricht chaotisch über verschiedene Themen. Ich glaube, mit anderen bin ich sehr ernst. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich bei meiner Familie sitze, mein Onkel hat wieder gesagt, weil dann hat er immer jemanden gefragt, so ja, was genau machst du denn jetzt eigentlich nochmal genau? Dann habe ich mir das erklärt, Drehbücher, was ist eigentlich? Ah, okay, spannend. Und dann kam es, ja und warum sollte ich jetzt, dann wurde es ein bisschen interviewig, warum sollte ich jetzt dich anrufen, wenn ich ein Drehbuch will?
Warum sollte ich jetzt ausgerechnet bei dir anrufen?
Und ich habe gesagt, ja, gut, es gibt jetzt nicht so viele Leute, die vor allem lustige Sachen schreiben wollen.
Und Expertise haben in lustigen Sachen in Deutschland gerade.
Das heißt, wenn du ein Produzent wärst, Herr Onkel, und nach einem lustigen Konzept-Aufersuch bist oder nach einer lustigen Sendung, dann würdest du vielleicht mal irgendwann auf mich stossen und mich vielleicht in der Bergung ziehen. Dann hat er gesagt, ach lustig, aber du bist doch gar nicht lustig. Habe ich da jetzt was verpasst eigentlich in letzter Zeit oder muss man dafür gar nicht lustig sein, weil er mich gar nicht zurückkommt. Ich glaube auch, dass er mich einfach für einen wahnsinnig ernsten Menschen hält, weil ich mit ihm auch vor ihm glaube ich noch keinen Gags gemacht habe. Er sagt doch immer, du bist ja eher wie ein ernster Mensch. Und hat er gesagt, aber irgendwo habe ich auch mal gehört, da war irgendwo ein Comedian zu Gast im Kölner Treff bei der Böttinger, die ist ja auch ganz toll. Ja, sie ist ja toll, sie ist ja fantastisch. Die ist ja auch so schleifend, die Sch Schöneberger, die mag ich ja auch so. Ja, da war jedenfalls jemand zu Gast und hat gesagt, er ist ja auch ganz anders als sein Job. Und so ist es bei dir, glaube ich, auch. Du bist halt gar nicht lustig, aber vielleicht kannst du das gut schreiben. Aber man ist ja auch nicht so, wie man im Job ist. Ja, da kann man wenig gegen sagen. Ich dachte, es ist so ein Scooby-Doo-Moment, wo dir die Maske vom Gesicht gerissen wird, wo du sagst, du verstellst dich doch gerade, sei mal so, wie du wirklich bist und sagst, ja stimmt, ich bin, wirfst dir ein Rotweinglas weg, holst die Tröte raus und bist wieder der normale Stefan. Ein Rad raus. Ja, aber fängst du an zu tanzen auf so einem Ball? Weinend aber. Ich will das nicht machen.
Ich dachte eher, du meinst es umgekehrt, dass er meine berufliche Maske runterzieht und dann kommt raus, ich klaue nur meine Gags. Ja, das ist halt die Frage. Ich glaube, die wenigsten Leute gehen davon aus, dass die Version, mit der sie gerade gegenüber sitzen, das nicht die reale ist. Sie sagen dann, ah ja, für deinen Beruf verstellst du dich, aber jetzt bist du gerade echt. Aber er würde wahrscheinlich nicht sagen, in deinem Beruf bist du du selbst, aber jetzt verstellst du dich gerade. Und es gibt wirklich Menschen, die mag ich nicht, mit denen will ich keine Zeit verbringen, aber ich mag mich sehr vor diesen Menschen. Und das glaube ich, das geht vielen Leuten da draußen auch so, weil man natürlich vor Leuten, die man nicht mag, oft befreiter auftritt, weil man denen nicht mehr beweisen will, weil man nicht geliebt werden will von denen, weil es fuck it, wer ist das denn jetzt schon? Und dann, ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt am Wochenende so eine Person, das darf ich glaube nicht sagen. Naja, war nicht in den Podcast oder sowas. Du hast am Wochenende eine Person getroffen, die du abgrundtief hast. Da war jemand dabei, im entferntesten Sinne, mal kurz, der oder die ich gar nicht mag. Und davor schon nicht mochtest oder hast du da erst erkannt, dass du die Person nicht nicht so gut bist? Nein, davor schon nicht, über Jahre hinweg schon. Alles da, also es ist eine Fehde. Nee, nicht Fehde, ich glaube, diese Person würde es auch gar nicht von sich behaupten und so, ist auch keine Person, die jetzt regelmäßig Zeit mit mir verbringen will, aber die ab und zu mal überschneiden sich mit den Freundeskreis. Und ich glaube nicht, dass diese Person sich dieser Fehde bewusst ist. Aber weiss Tarkan auch, dass du so fühlst? Ich glaube schon, ja. Okay. Ne, es ist nicht Tarkan. Tarkan und ich verbringen ja auch ganz gerne mal privat freiwillig Zeit miteinander. Das ist eine Person, die nicht mit mir so nahe ist. Und vor der Person bin ich aber wahnsinnig cool, finde ich. Man tritt befreit auf, man ist schlagfertig, man hat so eine kühle, coole Distanz. Ich finde mich wahnsinnig cool, wenn ich mit dieser Person, also ich finde auch so eine Zigarette immer und so einen Cowboyhut und so Sporen. Du musstest dann immer so sagen, du, ich habe morgen ein Date, könntest du vielleicht mitkommen, weil wenn du dabei bist, bin ich mega cool und sonst bin ich auf Dates immer so, mag mich, Hilfe, bitte mag mich und dann bin ich mega unsympathisch. Kannst du dich nicht so hinter dem Busch verstecken oder so, schon in Höheichweite? Es ist das grosse soziale Paradox, dass man vor den Menschen, vor denen es darauf ankommt, nicht cool ist, nicht performt. Und vor den Leuten, wo es scheißegal ist, befreit auftritt und cool ist. Das ist die grosse Gemeinheit. Du müsstest dich so primen, du müsstest dich erst mit deiner Hassperson treffen und dann so diese coole Person annehmen. Und vor allem, du kannst ja nicht, und dann muss es nie ein Überlappungsmoment geben, wo das Date kommt, weil du kannst dich ja innerhalb eines Kontaktes nicht ändern. Also das sind ja die interessantesten, wenn dann so Brückenmomente entstehen. Du bist mit deinem besten Kumpel bei deinen Eltern, bist auf Eltern getrimmt und dann kannst du aber schlecht wieder aus der Rolle raus und dann kommt dein Lehrer. und dann kommt das merkwürdige Sache. Wenn ihr zu Hause, wenn, keine Ahnung, mit einem Verwandten euch trefft oder sowas,
und danach kommen noch Kumpels vorbei oder ihr zieht los und sagt den Verwandten Tschüss, heute Abend noch verabredet und so weiter. Und dann trifft man aber mit dieser Person, die man den Tag über angenommen hat, dann auf Leute, die jetzt gar nicht oder noch schlimmer zwei Freundeskreide treffen, aufeinander. und alle kennen einen anders. Und ich denke mir, wenn jetzt verschiedene Sätze fallen,
verschiedene Anek Sätze fallen,
verschiedene Anekdoten fallen,
dann werden alle mich entlarven.
Und dann am Ende, du wirst du als grosser
Betrüger entlarvt, dir wird die Maske vom Kopf
gerissen. Sind wir nicht eh nur, spielen wir
nicht die ganze Zeit, haben wir nicht immer schon
die ganze Zeit gespielt, auch alle Leute, die sagen,
ja, jetzt neuerdings über Instagram und so
weiter, fangen Leute an, sich selbst darzustellen
und eine Person davon sich
ins Internet zu stellen oder eine Person
davon sich zu erfinden,
das ist so noch nie möglich gewesen, etc.
Glaub ich alles nicht.
Klar, ich meine auch so grosse Figuren der Geschichte,
Jesus oder so, wenn da irgendwie mal Lukas den Stift
zur Seite gelegt hat und gerade nicht mitgeschrieben hat,
dann war der für ein Name,
passt da gar nicht rein, wie Dennis. Ist es wie so Matthäus? Gab es eigentlich F***? Also hat man wirklich immer Jesus Christus von Nazareth oder hat man irgendwer ein Jesse oder Jesse? Jay. Oder hat man Jay gesagt oder ist das Spitzname ein modernes Konstrukt oder hat man wirklich schon bei Cäsar irgendwie Julius Jules gesagt? Jules.? Julesen oder so. Ich glaube schon, dass es kein modernes Konstrukt ist. Vor allem darum, Zeit zu sparen, oder nicht? Wahrscheinlich. So Charlie, Charlemagne, Charlie, was geht? Weißt du mal, wird nicht übertragen. C. Wird selten übertragen. Es gibt dann nur dieses, dass man so in der Mitte, so Spitznamen, die in der Mitte des Namens platziert werden. George W. Bush. Ich glaube nicht, dass W sein Spitzname ist. W. W, W, W, aber dass man dann sowas sagt wie, er ist denn über seinen Spitznamen. Dwayne The Rock Johnson. Ja, Dwayne The Rock Johnson, ja genau, Dwayne und in Anführungszeichen The Rock. Aber es hilft nicht, weil man immer sagt Dwayne The Rock Johnson. Und er immer The Rock reicht, deswegen habe ich das. Dwayne The Rock Johnson, komm mal hoch, bringst du ein Bier mit. Hey, Dwayne The Rock Johnson. Tatsächlich kann man sagen, dass der längste Name, den ich jemals gehört habe, wurde dann nicht zugelassen. Meine damalige Lehrerin, kann man das jetzt sagen, schon sehr lange her. Wahrscheinlich, kann man den Nachnamen jetzt verraten? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß, dass ich der Datenschutzbeauftragte dieses Podcasts-Projekts bin. Ja, ich weiß nicht auch. Aber ich war nicht auf dem Seminar, ich habe die Broschüre nicht gelesen, mein Internet ist gerade sehr, sehr langsam. Komm, sag mal, dann soll die Person Schäfer Tom Vasen hieß sie, Schäfer Tom Vasen, und sie hat geheiratet Herrn Brinktrine. So, jetzt kamen die beiden auf die tolle Idee, zu sagen, nennen wir uns einfach Schäfer Tom Vasen Brinktrine. Und das Formular war um einen Buchstaben zu voll. Nein, das heisst Brinktrine. Entweder Schäfer Tom Vasen Brinktrine oder Schäfer Tom Vasen Brinktrine, aber aber Schäferton war sen Bringtrine war nicht drin, jetzt ist es Frau Bringtrine.
Das ist schon schwierig, ne, mit den Namen. Da habe ich auch ein bisschen Respekt davor, dass wenn man mal irgendwann heiratet und dann dieses Gespräch führt, dieses Welcher jetzt schon, oder? Also, welcher wird's?
Oder ist's?
Also ich glaube, ganz viele Paare schieben das bis zu dem Standesamtmoment raus, oder keine Ahnung, wo man das festlegen muss, und dann schreibt man mal was in die Box und dann ist es auch schwer, da jetzt noch irgendwie vor dem Bischof dann irgendwie diese Diskussion zu starten. Schwierig. Vor dem Bischof? Da kommt dann der Bischof, vor dem Kardinal. Naja, aber macht nicht der Papst auch ein paar Hochzeiten so? Oh ja, gute Frage. Dass der halt so sagt, so, ach nö, das hat mir immer Spaß gemacht. Macht er nicht auch mal eine Beerdigung? Ja, bestimmt. Stell dir vor, du stirbst und dann so, und wer wurde eingeteilt? Ja, Papst halt, what? Und dann ist der halt da und stieh die Show und macht dann so seinen Zlam. Ja, stieh die Show, der macht dann so seinen Stuff, seinen coolen Papa-Stuff. Das würde mich echt ein bisschen nervig. Aber das sind, glaube ich, so ein Down-to-Earth-Papst, der auch mal sagt so, nö, ich mache das hier, ich gehe da hier zu den Schneiders, Frau und Herr Schneider, mache ich. Die Hochzeit mache ich. Aber wenn so Könige heiraten oder so, macht es schon der Papst persönlich, oder? Könige haben ja nicht mehr so viel zu sagen, Könige versucht man da eigentlich jetzt mittlerweile so wegzuignorieren. Aber ich glaube, der Moment kommt noch, oder? Denkt die Queen eigentlich noch, dass sie die Macht hat? Oder ist es so ein, also man sagt ihr, das ist wie so der kleine Bruder, dem man noch einen Controller gibt, aber nicht angeschlossen ist. So wie Goodbye Lenin, dass sie so eine Parallelwelt haben, wo die auch sagt, so, wir schicken jetzt dieses Schiff da nach Indien und alle so, okay, alles klar, Schiff nach Indien. Alles klar, sind unterwegs, die fahren los. Und dann hat man so 3D-Animateure, die dann so anfangen, das nachzubauen. Und dann zeigt mir die Live-Übertragung von dem Angriff. Und dann haben die das so nachgebaut oder so, zeigen so Szenen aus Pearl Harbor oder so. Guten Tag, Herr Premierminister von Indien. Grosse Ehre, dass jetzt die Queen besuchen, aber sie denkt immer noch, dass Indien in England gehört. Könnten Sie einfach ihr zuliebe einfach mitspielen, einfach sagen, ja, hallo, cool, danke, dass wir dabei sein dürfen im Empire. so es wäre super nett die hat jetzt noch drei, vier Jahre und es wäre uns super lieb, wenn sie einfach so tun, als wäre alles beim Alten. Sie denkt immer noch, dass es kein Coke Zero gibt, dass es immer noch nur Cola Light gibt. Diese ganzen neuen Vanilla Light, Vanilla Zero kennt sie alles nicht. Sie lebt in einer alten Welt. Sie müssen ihr sagen, dass es nicht mehr so ist. Ja, aber das wird sie nicht aushalten. Hören sie was von der Pandemie mitbekommen? Seien sie so nett. Nein, überhaupt nichts. Warum denkt sie denn, sind die ganze Strassen leer? Nein, nein, das weiss sie nicht. Die sitzt mit ihrem N64, sitzt sie in ihrem Zimmer. Von der Wii hat die noch nie was gehört. Noch nie von der Wii gehört? Schhh, sind sie wahnsinnig. Die darf nichts erfahren, wenn die erfährt, dass es die Switch gibt, die das nicht völlig durchgehabt. Sind sie wahnsinnig? Wie reden Sie eigentlich mit dem Premierminister von Indien? Wer sind Sie? Ich bin der Prinz Charles. Charlie. Nennen Sie mich Charlie. Ich nenne Sie Charlie. Meine Mutter, das wird die nicht ausheilen. Wussten Sie, dass Charlie der Spitznummer von Caesar war? Ja, ja, ja, das höre ich häufiger, das höre ich alle zwei Tage kriege ich auf Twitter eine Nachricht mit diesem genauen Inhalt. Ich weiss mittlerweile nicht mehr, wie ich darauf reagieren soll. Anyway, tun Sie mir den Gefallen und tun Sie einfach so, als wäre Indien immer noch in der Hand der Krone, okay? Okay, nicht so so. Alles klar, gut. Er wäre soweit. Rein mit ihm! Hallo, hallo Frau Green. Ah, Indien! Wie läuft es bei euch? Sehr gut, vielen Dank nochmal. Gerne, kein Problem. Gesetze und so. Kein Problem, ich habe ja gesehen, wie es euch geht und dann haben wir gesagt, komm, schmeißt die in den Einkaufswagen rein, die sind dabei und ja, also geht es euch gut so weiter und? Ich wollte nur mal perspektivisch fragen, ob es nicht langsam im Jahre 2020 mal Zeit wäre für Indien. Wie bitte? Im Jahre 1984. Ja genau, im Jahre 1984 vielleicht Zeit wäre jetzt für Indien, aber dass Indien auch um eigene Wege gehen kann. Ja, das ist nett, süss, das ist eine nette Idee, das ist eine nette Idee. Weil ja, Indien steht ja schon auf seinen eigenen Beinen, würde ich sagen, und deswegen fände ich es super, wenn wir die Unabhängigkeit reden. Ihr könnt euch ja mit Neuseeland zusammentun, vielleicht könnt ihr da was machen. Ach so, Sie denken auch, dass Neuseeland noch Teil von England ist?t, geht da zusammen und dann könnt ihr vielleicht irgendwie
eine neue Flagge oder sowas machen. Das wäre doch
nett. Dann sucht ihr euch eine neue Flagge
aus und dann schicken wir euch
irgendwie so ein paar Pralinen und dann machen wir das.
Okay? Gut.
Was ist das?
Was ist das denn? Was höre ich denn da?
Was sind das für himmlische
Klänge? Das habe ich noch nie gehört. Charles! Charles! Nein! Und so ist das Empire zusammengebrochen. So ist letztlich das Empire zusammengebrochen. Also falls ihr morgen noch ein Geschichtsreferat starten müsst, so ist das British Empire zusammengebrochen. Oh, das finde ich übrigens eine tolle Idee mal für einen Geschichtsaufsatz
zu Alternate History.
War nicht eigentlich jeder
Geschichtsaufsatz ein bisschen so, wenn man keine Ahnung
hatte und nicht gelernt hat und dann
hieß, wie ist das Römische Reich zusammengebrochen?
Ja, verschiedene
geopolitische Gründe natürlich. Das
jetzt auf einer Seite ist ein bisschen zu viel verlangt.
Jede zweite
Zeile wird beschrieben, immer eine Zeile Abstand,
damit der Lehrer noch was reinschreiben kann. Letztlich hat aber
Aber Verschiedene geopolitische Gründe natürlich. Das jetzt auf einer Seite ist ein bisschen zu viel verlangt. Jede zweite Zeile wird beschrieben, immer eine Zeile Abstand, damit der Lehrer noch was reinschreiben kann. Letztlich hat aber dann doch, muss man sagen, eine Pandemie. Und Gallien hat natürlich auch seinen Teil dazu beigetragen. Die Pandemie kam aus Gallien. Und im Markt, da ist nämlich eine Fledermaus angebissen. Genau, niemals Fledermaus. Reden wir nicht eigentlich viel zu häufig über das Römische Reich und viel zu selten über das Ägyptische Reich? Sehr gut, weiter. Weil war das Ägyptische Reich nicht eigentlich viel weiter und länger beständig und auch krasser, weil eher, was so ganz die ganze Zivilisation angeht und die ganzen Städte und wie die gelebt haben, war das nicht viel krasser? Warum wird das nie erwähnt? Ich glaube, Walk Like an Egyptian hat da viel von der Magie zerstört. Die haben halt so ein paar lächerliche Sachen gemacht. Ich sag mal, dass sie diese albernen Götter hatten, hat nicht geholfen. Das hat nicht geholfen. Albernen Bemalungen haben nicht geholfen. Nee. Pyramiden cool. Richtig cool.
So, aber auch diese Obeliske und so, diese hohen Spitzensachen.
Bisschen distinktiv alles.
Und dann, dass die Götter auch miteinander verschmelzen und so.
Und man sagt so, die beiden Götter gehören jetzt zusammen und so.
Das ist jetzt eins, das hat irgendwie, weiss nicht, das hat irgendwie die Fahrt rausgenommen.
Weil ägyptisch ist ja, also die Schriftzeichen, die Hieroglyphen sind ja ähnlich tot wie Latein. Ähnlich tot, mausetot. Naja, ich weiß nicht. Wenn ich jetzt sage, in dubio pro reo, kannst du damit mehr anfangen als Vogel, darüber kreuz, darunter ein kleiner Hund, der nach oben guckt. Gottra, Gottra, Gottra. Grosses Rad mit Strich durch, zwei Mücken oben links und rechts und rechts unten noch so ein Swoosh nach rechts oben. Damit kann es jetzt relativ wenig anfangen. Ja, aber doch nur, weil wir Latein künstlich am Leben halten. Weil bei uns doch Latein im Wachkummer liegt. Wir Intellektuelle, oder was? Ja, ja, klar. Wir halten diese Leichen noch oben. Wir halten ja Latein irgendwo noch am Leben, wohingegen ägyptische Hieroglyphen ja nie Thema ist. Ich war in New York kurz davor, mir das Buch mit dem wunderbaren Titel Ägyptische Hieroglyphen für Anfänger zu kaufen, wo ich mir dachte, ja, das trifft mich, da bin ich jetzt hier gekommen. Ja, da sind so ein paar Versuche noch, das am Leben zu erhalten. Ja. Und Latein wird so mit der Brechstange versucht, das am Leben zu erhalten. finde ich echt uncool. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe letztens tatsächlich eine Doku gesehen über Abu Simbel, das ist dieser große Tempel, der einmal verlegt wurde. Der wurde verlegt und der hatte irgendwie so ein krasses Feature, dass der an drei Tagen im Jahr scheint Sonne genau einmal durch den ganzen Tempel durch, so an dem Geburtstag von dem Pharao. Hitler ist Geburtstag leider. Stimmt, das ist aber auch so ein Ding, dass es irgendeinen Pharao gibt, der gesagt hat, ja, so ein Fluch, wenn ihr den Main-Sarg öffnet, dann wird ein Feldherr über die Welt herrschen, der viel grausamer ist als ich. Und dann haben sie diesen Deckel geöffnet und sie gesagt, scheiß drauf, AGB ist akzeptiert, halb gelesen, machen den Deckel auf, eine Woche später greift Hitler Polen an.
Nicht im Ernst.
Ja.
Und dann kann jemand einen coolen Film machen über zwei Archäologen, die jetzt sagen, scheiße, das ist unsere Schuld.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Wir hoffen, dass die Hitler die Schuld geben und sagen, was für ein Verrückter greift dann gerade die Welt an und wir sind ... Fuck!
Oder wir geben einfach die Schätze, die wir geklaut haben, wieder zurück in den Sarg. Co-Fuck. Andere Idee, wir versuchen den Krieg aufzuhalten. Wir fahren da hoch mit Fahrrädern. Wo brauchst du diese ganzen Goldketten? Und dieser Goldhut passt der gar nicht mehr. Wer findet, dem gehört es auch. Finders Keepers. Finderlohn macht Kinder froh. Also sorry, wenn du die Basics nicht kennst, kann ich dich als Archäologe nicht weiter ernst nehmen. Aber sind wir nicht Grabräuber? Nein, wir sind Archäologen. Ja, das sagst du immer. Aber wenn ich das meiner Frau erkläre, dann sagt die, wir sind Grabräuber. Nein! Dann erklärst du mir das immer so gut und dann denke ich mir, ja, du hast recht und meine Frau hat Quatsch. Überhaupt nicht. Nein, wir sind Wissenschaftler, die etwas über den Pharao herausfinden wollen. Oh, ich weiss, das macht Sinn, wenn du mir das sagst. Wenn ich das anderen Leuten sage, dann sagt niemand, nee, ihr seid einfach nur Grabräuber. Hör nicht auf deine Frau, die ist keine Wissenschaftlerin, die kennt sich damit nicht aus. Sag mir noch einmal, warum wir das behalten sollen und diesen Krieg stehen lassen sollen.
Weil der Pharao es so gewollt hätte.
Der hätte das doch nicht alles eingegraben, wenn das nicht mehr...
Das ist eine Art Schnitzeljagd.
Ich glaube, da oben steht auch in ägyptischen Hieroglyphen, macht das Grab nicht auf, nein, fickt euch, geht nach Hause, legt euch hin.
Wer von uns kennt sich mit Hieroglyphen jetzt besser aus? Ich glaube, keiner so richtig. Gut, da ist was dran, da bin ich jetzt auch sehr ehrlich, tatsächlich. Ich glaube, das ist aber, guck mal, das ist doch ein großes Stoppschild primär. Guck mal um, bevor wir diese Chiroglyphen nicht sehen, lesen können, das ist doch offensichtlich eine Art Stoppschild. Ja, aber das kannst du auch ironisch lesen. Pfarrer Ohren waren sehr ironisch, wenn man gesagt hat, oh, nimm bitte nicht mein Gold, oh, bitte werd nicht der reichste Mensch der Welt mit meinem ganzen Gold. Bitte lass mein Gold im Boden liegen, wo es niemandem was bringt, oh, das ist klug. So. So kann man es auch lesen. Ich sag nur, da ist der Grabeingang, dann ist da ein Kreuz drüber und daneben steht auf Englisch, bitte nicht betrieben. Das ist, das hat eine andere, Moment mal, siehst du das auch? Die Sonne geht auf, die Sonne leuchtet. Welcher Tag ist heute? 20. April.
Fuck!
Glaubst du, zwei Archäologen aus Ägypten hätten Hitler aufhalten können? Wenn sie so richtig gewollt hätten. Ja, ja. Ja, wenn die dann die Schätze zurückgegeben hätten, ist ja wie der Fluch des Cortes bei Fluch der Karibik immer noch einer der besten Filme aller Zeiten. Wenn man da nämlich alle Münzen zurückbringt, dann ist es vorbei. Führer Ober-Salzberg, Hitler wartet nur so, wie viele Münzen haben sie schon wieder drin? 99 von 100, machen wir weiter, Guderian, gib Gas, auf geht's. Und einer wartet dann nur, bis alle Münzen wieder zurück sind. Pressekonferenz. Ich liebe den ersten Bruder Riewick. Ein fantastischer Film. Ein wirklich fantastischer, überaus fantastischer Film. Eine fantastische Komödie, würde ich einfach sagen. Ja, ein Ulkstrudel, wie ihn die Welt noch selten gesehen hat. Ein Ulkgewitter, kann man sagen. Ein Ulksturm zieht herüber. Aber auch fantastische Musik. Also manchmal weiß ich es nicht. Fantastisch besetzt. Grossartig. William Turner. Tolle Geschichte. Es ist eine einfache Geschichte. William Turner, Orlando Bloom auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Karriere, könnte man vielleicht sagen. Als Schwertschmied, toll, tolle Figur. Und dann Elizabeth Swann, grossartig. Elizabeth Swann. Commodore Norrington, tolle Figuren. Was ist ein Commodore? Ehrlich gesagt, Commissioner Gordon, Commodore Norrington, diese ganzen Grade sagen mir nichts. Null, aber ich weiß noch, dass ich mich anschließend in Strategiespielen immer Commodore Florentin genannt habe. Commodore. Commodore. Und man wusste nicht genau, wie hoch es ist. Aber es gibt auch tatsächlich im ersten Fluch der Griebig diese eine Szene, wo man immer denkt, der Commodore ist der krasseste, aber dann gibt der andere, der Militärauffizier ihm Befehl und dem muss er dann gehorchen. Und da dachte ich mir schon als Kind, shit, jetzt habe ich nicht verstanden, wie die Hierarchie ist. Aber das war so ein Moment, so, oh, der darf dem was befehlen. Es gibt diese Szene. Wer darf ihm was befehlen? Ich weiß es nicht, wie der andere Norrington oder nicht. Commodore Norrington wird ja als Commodore befördert oder nicht. Oder wird er als Commodore zu was anderem? Nee, Commodore. Nee, nee, nee, nee, wir reden von zwei verschiedenen Figuren. Film. Was ist die? Ich rede von Bad Boys. Wie heißt der Vater von Elizabeth Swann? Das ist doch der Governor, Governor Sworn. Stimmt, aber ich glaube, es sind dann immer so, wenn zwei verschiedene Hierarchien interagieren, so einmal so eine, sagen wir jetzt mal Adelshierarchie, so was ist höher, ein Baron oder ein Major, so das ist dann schwierig zu sagen, weil es zwei verschiedene Hierarchien sind und dann muss man halt gucken, wieder die Konventionen und dann checkt man zuerst nicht, wer wem was sagen darf und dann so. Aber schwierig. Kann mal jemand so ein Organigramm von Flutter Karibik aufmachen? Genau, wo ist Regetti, wo sind die einzelnen Piraten, wo ist Barbossa? Kann Barbossa Commodore auch einfach sagen, ich bin der Kapitän? Ja, muss Commodore Neurton dann sagen, okay, ich frage kurz, wenn das okay ist. Weil der hat ja Schiffrecht, so lange sie auf dem Schiff sind, ist er der Kapitän der Höchste. Kann ein Commodore bei auf einem Schiff jemanden verheiraten? Ich glaube, nur sich selbst. Nur sich selbst und eine Person, die nicht allzu weit unter ihm steht. So zwei Stufen drunter geht das. Gut, dann habe ich keine weiteren Fragen. Ich fand es so lustig, dass bei Governor Swann, ich musste immer, als der neue Papst gewählt wurde und er kam auf diesem lustigen Balkon, habe ich gesagt, Governor Swann wurde zum Papst gewählt. Alles daran sah aus wie Governor Swann. Dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, dam, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, denn weil er sieht genauso aus wie sehr freut man sich als Schauspieler wenn jemand zum Papst gewählt wird er genauso aussieht wie man selbst ja absolut also auch bei Argo bei Argo hast du ja auch die um nochmals auf Argo zurückzukommen da hast du am Ende hast ja auch die ganzen Schauspieler und wie die echten Menschen aussahen und die wurden einfach nach Aussehen gekastet teilweise willkürlich nicht mal Schauspieler irgendwie ich spreche nicht mal Englisch aber die sehen halt so aus wie die Person und er funktioniert schon aber das ist schon das merkwürdigste Crossover aller Zeiten. Zwei Päpste und Flug der Karibik. Also ich weiß eh nicht, wo das Flug der Karibik Franchise gerade hin will, ob wer da gerade am Steuer ist und wohin der Wind weht. Backbord oder Steuerbord. Ja, oder ob man nicht irgendwie schon vor zwei Filmen den Anker hätte werfen sollen. Aber ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall ein gutes Crossover. Ich glaube, für mich ist seitdem Johnny Depp raus ist, auf jeden Fall, hätte man ein Manüberbord-Manöver. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Hart Steuerbord und dann Kehrtwende. Hatte Johnny Depp nicht im letzten Film sogar so Earpieces drin, wo ihm der Text gesagt wurde, weil er keinen Bock hatte, mehr Text zu lernen? Ich glaube, er wurde von einem anderen Schauspieler gespielt, aber mittlerweile, wie man das gemacht hat bei Irishman zum Beispiel, wurde er einfach komplett ersetzt, der ganze Körper wurde einfach, irgendwann hat Joni sich einmal scannen lassen, in so einem 3D-Scanner. Du, aber jetzt lachst du da noch keck drüber, aber vielleicht ist das die Zukunft, dass wenn du einen Star-Status hast, dass du dann einfach dein Gesicht verkaufst. Ein Star-Tus. Ja, ein Status, dass du dein Gesicht verkaufst und halt irgendwie so Nachwuchsschau-Spieler dein Körper sind, aber du halt dann, und dann so mit Voice-Erkennung und so hast du dann halt nur noch ein zangendes Gesicht von Brad Pitt, aber der war überhaupt nicht im Set. Genau wie Kevin Spacey will jetzt niemand mehr, zu Recht ja niemand mehr mitarbeiten und ist auch toll, wie das die Branche durchzieht, aber man muss einfach sagen,
der war ja nicht ohne Grund da, wo er ist,
auch wegen seines Gesichtes und man will ja den vielleicht auch noch mal
irgendwann in dem Film mal sehen, weil er
so ein sehr spezielles Face hat,
kann den nicht irgendein cooler Schauspieler jetzt spielen?
Hat der nicht sein Recht verwirkt,
zu entscheiden,
was mit seinem Gesicht gemacht wird?
Ja, okay, aber gut, was würdest du eher sehen?
Einen, sag ich mal, sauberen Schauspieler
mit dem Gesicht von Kevin Spacey
Und dann, wenn man die zu entscheiden, was mit seinem Gesicht gemacht wird. Ja, okay, aber gut, was würdest du eher sehen? Einen, sag ich mal, sauberen Schauspieler mit dem Gesicht von Kevin Spacey oder Kevin Spacey, der aber als Gesicht von einem anderen Schauspieler kriegt? Kevin Spacey soll nicht mehr arbeiten bekommen und arbeiten mit Leuten. Ich will aber Kevin Spacey weiterhin den Filmen sehen und genießen. Aber der kriegt ja nur Geld für sein Gesicht und muss ja eigentlich gar nicht... Warum ist es dir so wichtig, dass er nicht arbeitet? Soll es nicht wichtiger sein, ob er Geld bekommt oder nicht? Alles. Ich will nicht mehr, dass er mit Leuten in Kontakt tritt, die er mit seiner Macht missbrauchen kann. Also will ich jetzt zum Beispiel, weiss nicht, Timothy Chalamet soll Kevin Spacey personifizieren im neuen Film. Okay. Ja, gute Idee. Schreib ihn in die nächste Staffel How to Sell Drugs. Vielleicht hast du ja eine Chance. Ich schreib's in die Kommentare. Schreib's auch bei IMDB. Ja, oder in den aktuellsten Film einfach. Schreib's runter. Werbung. Jetzt mal Spaß bei der Seite kurz, okay? Spaß weg. Ja, Spaß bei der Seite. Weißt du, ob du versichert bist? Das ist ein wundes Thema, weil ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, welche Versicherung ich habe, welche ich noch brauche. Und ich glaube, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich irgendwann mal richtig in Schwierigkeiten komme, weil ich nicht die richtige Versicherung habe, ist extrem hoch. Werde ich jetzt wirklich ernst? Ja, das meine ich auch ernst. ernst. Ich weiß auch viel zu wenig darüber. Jetzt beim Umzug habe ich ein bisschen aufgeräumt in meinem Leben, weil man es ja auch machen muss, physisch. Deswegen weiß ich jetzt ungefähr, wo ich versichert bin. Aber es geht doch viel einfacher, nämlich mit der neuen App Clark. Und die gibt es erst seit 2015, hat aber mittlerweile schon 200.000 Kunden, weil du hast einfach deine ganzen Versicherungen in Einblick.
Und die App verrät dir sogar Tipps, wo du dich vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser versichern solltest, etc. Insider-Tipps. Insider-Tipps, alles kostenlos. Du musst nur in den App Store gehen oder in den Google Play Store, heißt es so, und musst dann da Clark suchen, C-L-A-R-K. Weil das nicht gut genug ist, legen wir da was oben drauf, nämlich ihr kriegt einen 30-Euro-Amazon-Gutschein, wenn ihr Clark herunterladet und euch dort registriert mit dem Code UFO30. Werbung. Aber ja, es könnte tatsächlich eine Zukunft sein, auch gerade jetzt zum Thema Podcast, man könnte natürlich sagen Stimmerkennungssoftware. Tatsächlich hat jetzt ein Kollege von mir ein Programm geschrieben, was er mal gemacht hat, hat durchlaufen lassen bei unserem Podcast, der die Ass rausfindet. Wow. Und zwar ist es im Prinzip ein automatisches Transkribieren eines Podcasts. Und deswegen kann er auch zum Beispiel die Ass rausfinden.
Das ist die Folge nur noch halb so lange.
Man kann es mit Audition verbinden und alle Ass rausschneiden.
Mega gut.
Ja, aber das ist bei uns doch ein Stückelwerk.
Das habe ich ja damals noch in Handarbeit gemacht. Da habe ich ja noch die kleine Nagelschere angesetzt.
Ja, wirklich?
Damals die ersten 50 Folgen, älfrei. Ja, hätte ich. Sehr viele Ers raus, sehr viele Pausen verlängert, dass das Timing besser ist oder verkürzt, dass die Gags noch mehr zünden. Und dann sind wir faul geworden. Dann sind wir faul geworden und dann kam das Geld. Das Geld kam erst, als die Schere beiseite gelegt wurde.
Du meinst, wir haben unsere Seele schon verkauft, bevor wir dafür Geld bekommen haben.
Dann ist es schon aus dem Fenster geworfen und dann hat jemand gesagt, hey, da ist Pfand drauf. Und du, scheiße, wie geht's? Sollen wir nochmal umdrehen? Kann man die Seele nicht weg, die Seele? Oh, apropos, wir haben ja, ich wollte es noch ganz kurz ansprechen, abschliessen, weil falls noch ein paar Leute hängen und ich glaube vor drei Folgen oder so haben wir gesagt, dass wir Wissenschaftler und Cornflakes kreuzen wollen, klassisches humoristische Operation, eigentlich ein Fingerspiel für Stefan Tietze, also Wissenschaftlernamen und Cornflakesnamen kreuzen. Da ist uns nichts eingefallen, nichts, wir waren blank, gar nichts. Das war glaube ich dreieinhalb Minuten Stille und da wollen wir euch auf jeden Fall nicht hängen lassen und deswegen hat Lucia hier nachgereicht und zwar hat Lucia uns oder Lucia, Lucia wahrscheinlich hat uns vier Wissenschafts-Cornflakes-Crossovers gegeben. Das sind vier mehr, als uns eingefallen sind. Richtig, Lucia hat vier mehr hingekriegt. Und zwar schreibt sie, Top vier Science Flakes, nennt sie es. Auf Platz Nummer vier, Curry Crisps, nicht ganz verstanden, aber dann, Ich bin nicht verstanden. Auf Nummer drei, Lion Schrödingers. Verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich verstehe es leider auch nicht. Lions. Wie hieß der mit Vornam Schrödinger? Lionel. Also gut, die ersten zwei sind da nicht ganz verstanden, aber es wird besser, pass auf.
Platz zwei, Cinevinci's, yes, und da haben wir ihn doch, Cinevinci's, fantastisch.
Eine sperrige Rubrik auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass Lucia sich die Herausforderung angenommen hat. Und auf Platz Nummer eins, mein absoluter Favorit, die Fruit Nudes. Yes! Lucia, yes! Fruit Nudes! Die Fruit Nudes. Vor allem, ich könnte mir wirklich vorstellen, dass Cornflakes so heißen. Es gibt ja auch die Fig Newtons. Oh, Fruit Newtons! Lucia, fantastisch, du hast das geschafft, was wir nicht geschafft haben, auch wenn ich die erstmal nicht verstehe, aber es ist nicht so wild. Bei Toplisten sind eh die Oberen die wichtigsten. Vielen, vielen Dank, Lucia hat uns nochmal aus der Tinte geholfen. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich habe auch einen bekommen und zwar Kellogg's Smacks Plank. Bisschen arg um die Ecke, also Maxplunk, Maxplunk, Smacksplunk, Kellogg's Smacksplunk. Also auch nicht schlecht, es könnte eine Top-4 für sich sein, aber Lucia, vielen, vielen Dank, grossartig. Ich kenne auch einfach zu wenig Serial-Marken. Das ist mein Problem. Cinevinci's? Sini Vinci's sind nicht gut, Fruit News.
Finde ich gut,
finde ich gut. Wir haben externe Gags
jetzt auch im Podcast. Also
ich finde, wenn unsere Zuschauerhörer lustiger
sind als wir, können wir das auch gerne eingestehen.
Dann müssen wir das auch eingestehen. Das ist eine
ehrliche Kollaboration. Das ist auf jeden Fall die Regel.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist nicht sehr gut.
Und ich finde, Lucia hat sie auf jeden Fall geschafft.
Und ja, ich würde sagen, den Nobelpreis, den Comedy-Nobelpreis für diese Woche geht an Lucia.
Der geht jede Woche an ihn.
Ja, ja.
Also bis jetzt gab es halt leider nie Kandidaten, aber wir haben ihn jetzt das erste Mal.
Warum ist kein Comedy-Nobelpreis?
Ja, schwer zu sagen. Comedypreis, Kölner Comedypreis, ist das einzige.
Er hat mal einen Comedian den Literaturnobelpreis bekommen, weil er streng genommen Schreib erzeugt ist. Hat nicht Otto Walkers einen bekommen? Ah ja, Otto Walkers hat einen bekommen. Ich glaube schon, Otto Walkers hat einen bekommen. Aber war ja der grosse Disput nicht wegen der Filme, sondern wegen der Autifanten. Ach so. Wegen der Autifantenbücher, ja. Und ich glaube, Ralf Schmitz auch, aber eher für seine Musik. Und seine Aufregel in der Schillerstrasse, diese eine Folge. Wie gut das denn wäre. Ralf Schmitz bekommt einen Nobelpreis einfach so aus dem Nichts heraus. Für sein herausragendes Engagement. Das ist aber so, weil er da jemanden kannte. Weil er hatte da so Connections hin.
Ja, ich kannte die Tochter von dem Jury-Hauptanführer.
Da hätte ich Lust drauf, mal so eine Mockumentary zu machen.
So eine wenig so 90 Minuten Mockumentary, meinetwegen auch für Spotify, Spotify Original.
Und dann so eine ausgedachte Geschichte.
Zum Beispiel das Jahr, in dem Ralf Schmitz den Comedy-Nobel Nobelpreis gewann. Dann gehen wir dem Ganzen mal auf die Schliche. Wie konnte das sein? Wie konnte das passieren? Fände ich wahnsinnig lustig. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Machen wir mal. Ich habe gestern auch wieder einen Film gesehen, ich glaube, es gibt eine ganz eigene Kategorie von Filmen, Mark Ruffalo Investigativ. Schaue ich mir immer gerne an. Mark Ruffalo, der gute Fragen stellt und aufmerksam zuhört, ist für mich der perfekte Abend. Kann ich mir den ganzen Tag angucken. Mir fällt nur Spotlight und Zodiac ein. Spotlight, Zodiac und jetzt gibt es Dark Waters. Er spielt dieselbe Figur nochmal. Er spielt auch im Kern immer Mark Ruffalo. Bei Zodiac spielt eigentlich Jake Gyllenhaal den Mark Ruffalo, aber ähnliche Figur. Stimmt, Jake Gyllenhaal spielt den Mark Ruffalo, Mark Ruffalo ist aber auch dabei, aber so ein bisschen, als wäre er erwachsen geworden aus dieser Mark Ruffalo-Rolle halt raus. Aber er kommt nicht raus. Die Leute wollen dich als Investigativ sehen. Oh, ich finde, Zodiac ist ein fantastischer Film. Oh, grossartig. Ich finde das mit der beste Film, ich mag den so gern. Ich mag vor allem auch die Robert Downey-Junior-Figur natürlich total gern. Ho, alles darin. Den Film kann ich mir bestimmt einmal im Moment angucken. Fantastisch, und er ist ja extrem detailgetreu, so auch was die Kostüme der Opfer angeht und so, das ist alles ganz genau nachempfunden. Klar, von der Geschichte her natürlich ein bisschen dramaturgisch aufgepeppt und so und zusammengezogen. Geiler Soundtrack, Hurdy-Gurdy-Man läuft achtmal, toll. Und natürlich auch was visuelle Effekte angeht, natürlich fantastisch, weil ja unfassbar viele visuelle Effekte drin sind, man die aber nicht sieht.
Genau wie bei Parasite, ein fantastischer Film, wo fast alles quasi vor Blau gedreht wurde.
Also dieses ganze Haus wurde auch gebaut ja extra für den Film, fantastisch.
Und die eine Tochter ist komplett CGI, also das war immer nur Wesen mit Tennisball am Set.
Mark Ruffalo spielt tatsächlich die eine Tochter.
Ich bin jetzt so lustig bei den Avengers, wo ja die ganze Zeit Avengers, wo ja die ganze Zeit die ganzen nur den Kostümen sind, außer Mark Ruffalo, weil der ja Hulk ist. Ja. Aber der ist die meiste Zeit ja nicht Hulk, eher sind in den Filmen.
Und im Prinzip sind es immer Superhelden und Mark Ruffalo, der ja auch in seiner anderen Figur jetzt primär davon lebt, Mark Ruffalo zu sein, und nicht weil die Figur besonders dreidimensional Tiefe hat und so. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass bei diesem Avengers Headquarters irgendwie Tor geht rein und der Partner so Morgan, Morgan, Black Widow, Morgan und Mark Ruffalo. Kann ich mal Ihren Ausweis sehen? Ich bin der Heilige, ich bin Bruce Banner. Ich bin Mark Ruffalo. Ah, okay, Bruce Banner. Aber das würde ich so, er könnte einfach Mark Ruffalo heißen, ich würde auch nichts ändern, großartig, im Ernst. Nee, aber es ist großartig einfach, warum nicht? Aber Dark Waters kann ich euch empfehlen, basiert auf einer wahren Geschichte, fantastische Geschichte. Wo schaust du, Phil, wo schauen wir das Filme? Vorhin auf iTunes, die kippen die Chemikalien in den See rein. Was? Die kippen die Chemikalien in den See rein und dann sterben die Kühe und Mark Ruffalo sagt, was ist da los? Warum denn? Tatsächlich gab es einen grossen Skandal, dass sie irgendwelche Chemikalien in denen gepumpt haben. Und dann wurden auch Kinder deformiert geboren. Und in dem Film tritt eines von diesen tatsächlich, die hat so ein verschobenes Auge, tritt der tatsächlich auf, der tatsächlich von diesen Chemikalien diesen Geburtsdefekt hat. Der tritt in dem Film auf die echte Figur, auch als er selbst. Fand ich fantastisch. Wo ich mir dachte, wow, wo kriegt man einen Schauspieler her, der genau die richtige Verschiebung hat, wie diese Kinder, die da unter diesem Einfluss, die sich im Kai geboren wurden. Du hast direkt Google angeworfen. Nee, sagt der Film selber. Wie? Wir sind im Schnittraum und sagen, so, kannst du noch kurz einen Kaffee holen? Ich bin Mark Ruffalo und Sie schauen gerade den Film Dark Waters. Dark Waters. Sie haben sich wahrscheinlich gefragt, warum das so aussieht. Kein CGI, es ist tatsächlich die echte Person. So ein Reinfahr-Promi, wie unten in der Schadshow. Ja genau, man fährt unten so Mark Ruffalo rein. Und dann kommt Nils Bogleberg rein. Jetzt in dieser Szene mal kein Besonderes, dass das tatsächlich die echte Figur ist. Finde ich nicht schlecht, finde ich ganz gut. Ich bin noch nicht darüber hinweg, über meine Müdigkeitsphase, wo man noch keine Erklärung hat liefern können. Aber hast du ein CO-Kohlenmonoxid? Ich habe noch mal einen Film angefangen, Her, wieder eingeschlafen, den kannte ich auch schon, aber ich mache mittlerweile noch Filme an, die ich schon kenne, weil ich den nicht mehr verpasse. Aber weil du denkst, okay, jetzt bin ich eingeschlafen, aber ich kenne ihn eh schon.
Ja, genau.
Aber hat Kohlenmonoxid mal getestet irgendwie?
Nee, weiß ich nicht wie.
Da gibt es ja nicht so ein Experiment.
Aber immer wenn ich so los will, um ein Experiment zu kaufen, bin ich so ...
Immer so die Google-Suche, Kohlenmonoxid testet.
Jetzt ist es doch los.
Jetzt ist es doch los im Baumarkt. Warum bin ich so müh? Kugel kann einem nicht weiterhelfen. Von daher komme ich nicht so richtig weit. Aber es kann gut sein. Lass das mal nochmal offen. Ich finde es so lustig, dass diese Storyline jetzt diese Wendung nimmt, aber ich bin derjenige, der jetzt beauftragt wurde. Also meine Nachbarn fahren in Urlaub. Meine Nachbarn fahren in Urlaub. Warum sollte die Information mit irgendwas zusammenhängen, was wir besprochen haben im Podcast? Gute Frage, Leute. Meine Nachbarn fahren in Urlaub und meine Nachbarin war diejenige, die sich immer um die Kaninchen gekümmert hat, die Luisa zerstört hat, die Luisa angefahren hat, totgedrückt hat. So, da gibt es jetzt noch, das war ja vor ein paar Jahren, mittlerweile vermehren sich ja wie Scheiße. Jetzt haben wir mittlerweile wieder vier Weizkaninchen auf der Strasse. Also drei weitere potenzielle Opfer. Und meine Nachbarin ist diejenige, die denen immer Karöttchen und Salätchen abends auf die Strasse wirft. Wenn die das mal vergisst, stehen dann da alle Kaninchen unten vor dem Haus und schauen hoch. Moment mal, die leben auf der Strasse? Die leben auf der Strasse. Und meine Nachbarin ist die, die die füttert immer jeden Abend. Und jetzt fährt meine Nachbar in Urlaub und wen hat hat sie beauftragt die kaninchen zu füttern der schläfrige stefan stefan stefan schläfi tize ja jetzt da ich denke es gibt sie mir weil sie weil ich ja immer einschlafe bevor ich zum einkaufen komme gibt sie mir Karöttchen und Salätchen und dann muss ich jetzt für zwei Wochen muss ich jetzt die füttern Wow, aber das das ist schon sehr niedlich ehrlich gesagt. Ist sehr niedlich. Es ist sehr niedlich und die stehen dann wirklich so hungrig davor und dann wirfst du einmal am Tag nur. Ja, vor allem die wohnt ja wie neben mir direkt, also so im zweiten Stock, also nicht unten direkt, sondern die wirft einfach von oben immer auf die Kaninchen, Karotten und Salat und die essen das immer jeden Tag. Wie kann man denn eigentlich davon leben? Hat das nicht wahnsinnig wenig Kalorien Salat? Kann man denn davon leben? Auch wenn ich so Pferde sehe, die ja unfassbar muskulös sind und gross sind, immer auf der Weide, immer an Gras nuckeln. Also gerade Salat hat ja wirklich, also fast keine Kalorien. Wie kann man, das ist ja Wahnsinn. Soll ich den mal ein Snickers oder so? Aber du hast, du tunkst die schönen Soße Hollandaise davor, oder was? Ja, die kriegen schon noch so sein. Dann kommt sie wieder aus dem Urlaub und dann so dicke Bälle da rum. Verwachsen miteinander. Verwachsene, dicke, picklige Cholesterin-Bälle. Gibt es eigentlich so ein Kletttier, das so wie so Klettverschluss hat als Haare? Weil es so faul ist, dass sich so an andere dran klettet. Ja, vielleicht geht's gut.
Oh, da kommt dann irgendwie so ein Panther vorbei und der so klettet sich einfach dran und fährt ein Stück lang mit. Das finde ich ganz gut. Ich glaube, es gibt ja so Pflanzen, die so Widerhakenfühler haben, die sich da irgendwo dranhängen und so. Ja, genau. Aber Tiere haben das noch nicht gemacht. Die sogenannten Kletten. Tatsächlich. Richtig. Aber ich frage mich mittlerweile, was die Leute von mir halten. Man kann ja alle die Chance, eine neue Person aufzubauen, wenn man eine neue Gegend zieht. Und manchmal hat man das nicht ganz in der Hand. Weil gestern Abend, super spät, um neun Uhr kam noch ein Paketboot von Hermes an. Super spät, war ich gar nicht mehr darauf gefasst, war auch schon wieder wahnsinnig müde, dann kam der Typ, hat mir dann zwei sehr, muss man sagen, eigentlich die identischen Pakete gegeben. Das waren so, ich habe so T-Shirts bestellt oder sowas und Nachbar offensichtlich auch. Und dann kam zwei, habe ich zwei Pakete bekommen und dann habe ich, eines war für die Nachbarn, eines von mir habe ich netterweise angenommen, hingelegt auf meinen Schreibtisch und dann habe ich es aufgemacht, eins, um meine T-Shirts rauszuholen. Was hatte ich in der Hand? Drei BHs und so Höschen. Oh, wie viele Höschen? Zwei. Drei Oberteile, zwei Unterteile? Ja, verschiedene Höschen. Das ist ja schon Tragödie vorprogrammiert. Nicht passend zum BH. Okay. Heißt aber, und ich bin direkt in Scham versunken, weil ich habe offensichtlich das falsche Paket aufgemacht. Ja. So. Wie soll ich jetzt jemandem erklären, übrigens, schöne BHs, die du da bestellt hast, wie unangenehm ist das denn? Aber wie hast du es denn geöffnet? Hast du es wirklich aufgerissen? Aufgerissen! Warum reisst du es denn auf? Weil ich dachte, das sind meine Shirts, die ich behalte. Bist du so ungeduldig und willst dein Fashion-Kick oder was? Fashion-Kick! Aber kannst du jetzt nicht einfach dein Paket vorsichtiger aufmachen? Da ist meine Adresse drauf. Ja, aber dann klebst um, klebst um. Mach dein Paket sanft auf, so dass du es gut verschliessen kannst, tu die fremden Sachen da rein, verschliess es, kleb die Adresse des Nachbarn drauf und gib es zurück. Bei ihr steht aber dick und fett H&M auf dem Paket drauf, weil es ein H&M-Paket ist. Ja, aber das merkt die nicht. Gebrandet. Die sagt doch nicht, Moment mal, das Paket ist da, aber da steht nicht H&M drauf. Bei mir steht Skatershop, hast du nicht gesehen, drauf. Das hat ja nicht bestellt. Kannst du nicht so von auf links drehen, das Paket? Scheiße. Ich habe das aufgemacht, hatte den B.A. Heinehand und dann kam die Musik von Curbio Enthusiasm. Prinzipiell. Scheiße. Das war, ja, gut. Mal gucken, was ich jetzt damit mache. Vielleicht gebe ich sie ihr und spiele mit offenen Karten. Dann bringst du dein Paket mit und sagst, die sehen sich schon sehr. Aber hast du denn nicht verstanden, als du zwei Pakete bekommen hast, dass eins nicht für dich ist? Oder dachtest du, beide sind für dich? Doch, doch schon. Du hast verstanden, dass eins nicht für dich ist und hast dann beim auf du bist all in gegangen einfach unnötigerweise all in gegangen ist gesagt ich mache jetzt eins dieser beiden unwiederschliessbar auf nee ich habe mir schon was dabei gedacht was denn das interessiert mich jetzt weil du hast ja nicht die adresse angeguckt das was dir dabei geholfen hätte weil ich bei einer firma bestellt habe die die eine Tochterfirma ist, von dem Logo, was bei ihr drauf war.
Und ich sage immer wieder, dein Wissen über die Modeindustrie hält dich zurück, steht dir im Weg. Ja, und scheiße, mir steht Wissen manchmal total im Wege. Ja, du weißt so viel, welche Firma Tochter von H&M ist. Das muss man nicht wissen. Doch, ich habe bei einer Firma bestellt und ich bin mir sicher, dass so eine, ich irgendwo gelesen, dass die Tochterfirma, was man nicht weiß, weil H&M es auch geheim hält einigermassen, weil man da nicht mehr kaufen würde sonst, von H&M ist. Und dann war auch bei ihr ein H&M-Logo drauf und dann habe ich gesagt, ah, das wird das wohl sein, habe es aufgerissen und hole dann HBHs raus. So eine Scheisse. Jetzt, ich schaue, ich kann ausziehen jetzt. Aber wie sehr hast du es denn aufgerissen? Ist das wirklich irreparabel kaputt? Ja. Nee, es ist schon vorsichtig aufgerissen, aber es ist jetzt nicht, also es ist heute offen, es ist offensichtlich offen. Schwierige Situation. Aber ich würde es so tun, als dass ich es nicht geöffnet hätte. Nee, das ist mir viel zu viel. Nein, nee, nee, nee. Ich sage, ich habe es geöffnet und ich habe jeden einzelnen BH angeguckt und meine persönlichen Bewertungen liegen dabei. Aber es ist ja schon komisch, weil sie wird ja nicht davon ausgehen. Also entweder, du wusstest ja nicht, dass Unterwäsche drin ist. Wenn das jetzt irgendwie Victoria's Secret gebrandet wäre, dann könnte man dir niedere Instinkte unterstellen, wenn du es öffnest.
Wogegen H&M kann ja alles sein, aber auf der anderen Seite, naja, das ist schon...
Ich gehe zu ihr und sage...
Ich würde vermeiden, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Schau mal, stell dir vor, versetz dich mal in sie, sie denkt, ich wohne neben jemandem, der offensichtliche Kleidungslieferung, bei H&M muss Kleidung sein, von mir aufreißt und dann so tut, als hätte er es nicht verstanden. Niemand ist so dumm. Viel schlimmer ist zu sagen, der so tut, als er das nicht aufgerissen hat. Doch, nein, okay, naja, okay, okay, okay, verstehe ich, aber du musst es ja schon so widerschenen Karten, ich sage, oh. Nein, spiel nie mit offenen Karten, Stefan, hast du denn gar nichts gelernt? Hat man vor allem, in welchem Universum ist das ein Tipp? Weil hat mal jemand jemals Poker gewonnen, weil er mit offenen Karten gespielt hat? Nein. Das ist nie gut. Du nimmst entweder deinen Karton oder einen anderen Karton, der so ähnlich aussieht, egal wie er gebrandet ist, neutral, tust da die Sachen rein, klebst ihre Adresse drauf, verschließt es fachmännisch, gibst es ihr, kein Mensch der Welt sagt, oh, das ist aber nicht original verschlossen, niemand. Und wahrscheinlich hat sie in ihrer Wohnung so einen ganzen Stapel H&M-Karton, die alle exakt gleich aussehen, und legt so den drauf und merkt, Moment mal. Was, dann geht sie erst weg und dann bleibt sie stehen. Wir sind so mit der Kamera nah auf ihr.
Die Kamera schwenkt sie aus dem Fenster, zoomt zu deinem Fenster, wo du mit so einem Weitwinkelobjektiv in ihre Wohnung schaust. Und dann so ganz schnell runter gehst. Ich werde es folgendermaßen machen. Während du mir deine Lösung vorgetragen hast, ist mir klar geworden, ich will mit offenen Karten spielen. Nein. Ich gehe zu ihr hin und sage hi, und zwar habe ich auch ein H&M-Paket bekommen, ich lüge ein bisschen, es sah genau so aus, ich habe ausser den Deins aufgemacht, es tut mir total leid. Schöne Schöne Schöne Abend. Körbchengrösse.
Hast du denn zu viele Unterwäsche, Unterteile, dass du jetzt eine ungleiche Anzahl bestellst?
Weil wechselt man denn das eine unabhängig vom anderen?
Weil wenn man immer beides gleichzeitig wechselt, dann warum bestellt sie unterschiedlich viele Oberteile wie Unterteile? Das hab ich auch nicht verstanden. Jetzt war ich aber auch nicht ... habe ich nicht alles durchwühlt in diesem Paket, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich hab mal reingeguckt, du hast fünf Teile rausgenommen, bevor du gesagt hast, okay, jetzt bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass es nicht meins ist. Nach drei BHs dachtest du dir, na, vielleicht hatte ich einen schwachen Moment.
Erst dachte ich auch, die haben mir alles falsch geschickt.
Und dann war erst, ah, ich habe das falsche
Bild aufgemacht. Weil du dir ein Garfield-T-Shirt
bestellt hast und es war ein Garfield-BH,
dachtest du dir, ah, okay, naheliegender Fehler.
Oder es ist der Beginn einer wundervollen Love-Story,
weil eigentlich passen wir wahnsinnig gut zusammen,
weil sie die Garfield-BHs hat, ich habe das Garfield-Shirt bestellt.
Ich habe auch überlegt schon, ihr mein Paket zu geben und zu sagen, oh hier, das ist genial, das ist ja viel besser. Jetzt zu sagen, hier wurde ein Paket für dich abgegeben und dann sagt sie, bringt das vorhin wieder vorbei und sagt, du hast mir das falsche Paket gegeben. Und ich sag, oh, dann habe ich gerade eben, bevor du klingelst, das falsche Paket aufgemacht. Oh, na Gott sei Dank habe ich noch nicht reingeguckt. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, nee, nee, du musst dann, wenn sie klingelt, musst du mit so einem Teppichmesser in der Hand dastehen. Oh mein Gott, das ist perfekt! Und dann so, oh, ich wollte auch gerade, oh, das ist aber schwer zu timen.
Das ist perfekt, nee, ich muss immer einfach ein Teppichmesser an meiner Tür haben und in dem Moment, wo sie klingelt, sage ich, ich habe es gerade aufgemacht.
Aber was ist, wenn sie einen Zettel schreibt oder so und dann eine Tür klebt und so etwas sagt wie, hey, wir haben anscheinend, ich habe bei dir vier Dildos im Paket gehabt, da muss irgendwas nicht stimmen, ich glaube, wir müssen wieder austauschen. Dilden. Dilden. Und dann kannst du nicht so tun, als würdest du gerade dabei ertappt werden. Oh, das ist schwierig. Ich will nicht sagen, du kriegst das nicht hin, aber das ist nicht ganz leicht. Da rauszukommen jetzt. Aber das ist eine totale Sackkasse. Nee, gibbt ihr dein Paket, dass sie es öffnen, und dann seid ihr auf einem ähnlichen, schlechtes Gewissen Niveau, und dann könnt ihr es einfacher austauschen. Die wird es nicht öffnen, weil ganz gross ein anderer Markenname draufsteht. Und bei mir macht da noch Sinn, weil meins ist eine Tochterfirma von A&M. Das weiß kein Mensch! Aber hier. Sie wird sich nicht denken, Moment mal, das ist ja eine Tochterfirma, Moment, Anteilseigner, ungefähr 40 Prozent, aber vertreten im Vorstand. Sperrminorität. Da ist doch was falsch gelaufen. Ich habe doch hier bei der Mutterfirma bestellt, Anteilseigner, Geschäftsführer seit 2018, Herbert Griesel. Sperrminorität seit drei Jahren. Das hat doch gar keinen Sinn. Niemand kennt sich so gut in der Modeindustrie aus wie du, Stefan. Ich kenne nicht so gut in der Modebranche aus. Es hält dich zurück, es stellt dir ein Bein. Ja. Es stellt dir einfach ein Bein. Bist du dir denn sicher, dass du es wirklich aus Versehen aufgemacht hast? Ich? Ja. Waren dann nicht, ohne dass du es weisst. Selbst du wirfst mir jetzt schon ihre Instinkte vor.
Das wird nicht gut ausgehen, diese Geschichte.
Eben, deswegen, tu so, als wäre es nie passiert.
Probleme werden ignoriert.
Tu so, als würde das Problem gar nicht bestehen.
Aber das ist doch, ich muss es ja, also, weil ich habe es auch schon gesehen, es hat diese Laschen, diese wiederverschliessbaren Laschen.
War es das Paket?
Ja. Also ich kann es einfach wieder schliessen, aber es sieht offensichtlich geöffnet aus. Na, das ist unscheinend, das alles, das macht gar keinen Sinn, das jetzt irgendwie groß zu, wahrscheinlich hört ihr auch den Podcast und ja, jetzt lachen wir alle drüber und so. Oh Gott. Mir wird ganz trümmlich. Ich würde es schliessen, ich würde es versuchen zu schliessen. Selbst wenn es geöffnet ist, kannst du immer noch sagen, ja, es ist komisch, manchmal kommt... Ich habe schon überlegt, es wegzuwerfen. Echt? Ja, er kann mir auch überlegen. Und dann aber diesen Zettel im Briefkasten, dass ich es angenommen habe. Nee, ist kein Paket für sich angekommen. Und dann kommt eines der Kaninchen angehoppelt und hat so ein BH eingeklemmt. Was ist denn mit dir? Moment mal. Und so ein schmatzendes Kaninchen in Klaus. So ein Kreisblende. Ein Kreisblende auf das Auge, ja. Das Kaninchen. Bing. Ich meine, du wirst eh schlafen, während sich das alles abspielt. Ja, wenn die Horrorszenen passieren, werde ich auf der Türschwelle eingeschlafen sein. Ist ganz, ganz ... Ich locke die einfach zu mir in die Wohnung, bis sie auch einschläft.
Das ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Und dann tausch das Paket aus. Ja, das ist auch schwierig, wenn jemand einschläft in einem Horrorfilm. Ich habe mich letztens daran erinnert, weil ich habe überlegt, ob ich einen Horrorfilm gucken soll. Habe ich nicht gemacht. Aber wir haben ja mal überlegt, aber das ist eines dieser zu weirden Konzepte, einen Sketch zu drehen aus der Perspektive des Monsters. Was die ganze Zeit einfach nur wartet. Genau, was die ganze Zeit so hinter dem Sofa lauert. Ist aber schwer zu sagen, weil oft aus der Perspektive des Opfers, des Horrorfilms läuft sie durch die Gegend und plötzlich steht sie vor der Tür. Ja, Jumpscare. Jumpscare, aber wie lange steht das Monster schon da? Ja. Also will ich schon seit einer halben Stunde und denkt sich, jetzt aber guter Platz, aber ihr habt so diese, die Räuber, die hinter der Rückbank warten, bis derjenige einsteigt. Was ja wahnsinnig gruselig ist in dem Moment, wo die aufschrecken, aber eigentlich warten die ja schon drei Stunden in der Tiefgarage im Auto. Das war ja leider nicht machbar, der Sketch. Wir haben leider keine Drehung bekommen. Wir haben die Drehung nicht hinbekommen. Wir haben es nicht verstanden, aber wir wollten ja auch, Horror ist echt ein schweres, wir wollten ja auch einen Horror Trailer machen. Einen Horror Trailer, für diese Fake Trailer von guter Arbeit ganz am Anfang wollten wir auch einen Horror Trailer machen. Ich bin froh, dass wir das nicht gemacht haben, weil ich glaube, das ist fucking schwer, einen vernünftigen Horror-Trailer zu machen, der auch wirklich gruselig ist auf eine Art. Weil er sollte ja wirklich gruselig sein, weil wenn es so ein Comedy-Horror-Trailer ganz unabhängig ist. Da habe ich mir tatsächlich dafür, weil es gab Skripte auch dann dafür. Ja, da gab es sechs Versionen. Und tatsächlich weiss ich noch, dass man sich da mal einen Film ausgedacht hat.
Unter anderem dann, wo ich glaube, ihr beiden in einem, und da habe ich auch echt Bock drauf, das mal zu machen, waren aber geklaut von Oblivion, wie mir nachher einfiel. Ihr beiden wohnt nämlich in einem Haus, irgendwo in der Pampa-Ferien. Also Katja und ich, ja. Katana, du, und dann irgendwann verstreitet ihr euch und dann gehst du wütend in den Wald, gehst spazieren alleine und stößt wieder auf ein Haus, was genauso aussieht wie euer Haus, wo es aber auch ein Flur und die Katja gibt, die sich auch gerade streiten oder sowas vielleicht. und ja es ist so eine Mischung aus Ass und Oblivion ein bisschen, aber nicht schlecht,
nicht schlecht, aber das ist, ich glaube das Problem bei solchen Horrorkonzepten ist immer cool also diese Entdeckungsmomente sind ja das Gruselige wo du merkst ach du scheiße aber was nicht cool ist sind die Auflösungsmomente dieses ja da gab es in den 80ern atomares Experiment dadurch wurden Dimensionsrisse aufgemacht deswegen existiert das ganz oft so. Erkläre ich. So und dann halt, ja, passt, ciao, macht's gut. Wir sehen uns bald halt. Das ist auch die einzige Szene, die bei Hereditary da nicht mag, dass dann irgendwie das Monster Loro ist, was seit 80 Jahren spukt. Ja, ich finde, Enden bei Horrorfilmen sind immer extrem schwer, weil Enden sind per Definition das Gegenteil von Horror, weil du fängst an, Dinge zu erklären und klarer zu machen. Ja, und Horror lebt ja davon, dass man von Mystery... Ja, genau, und denkt sich, what, krass, so, und deswegen ist es eigentlich immer so, oh, geil, und dann eigentlich müsste man da aufhören. Horrorfilme debunked. Ja. Florentin Will debunked Horrorfilme. Ja, es ist geschehen, ja. Destroys Horror Movies. Florentin Will, German Comedian, destroys Horrories forever. And for everyone. You will never see Horror the same way again. Horror is dead. This man killed it. Horror is undead. It never lived. Das war die Postillon-Meldung. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht, was du sagst. Also lass uns vielleicht nicht keinen Horrorfilmer machen. Lass uns auf die anderen Filme konzentrieren, die wir noch haben, in der Schublade.
Ja, ja, wir haben ja noch einige.
Das mit dem Monument.
Das Monument, the Moment, the Monumentum.
The Monumentum.
The Conspiratist, Conspiratist, Conspiratist, The Planeator.
The what?
The Planeator. Nee, der andere Film, Theator, The What? The Planeator?
Nee, der andere Film, The What.
The What, The What What?
Aber es gibt ja The Who, gibt es nicht auch eine Band, die The What heisst?
Wir kommen auf der Bühne, The What!
The What?
What?
That's Us.
Who?
Genialer Bandname, The Who.
Das war es für die Zeit, The Who, The When. Von allen Fragewörtern ist Who der Beste. The Who? Brillant. Fantastisch. Gibt es eigentlich irgendeine Möglichkeit, Webseiten-Ideen? Bandnames.org Es gibt ja Bands, die können gut Musik machen, aber die sind vielleicht nicht die besten darin, sich Bandnamen zu überlegen. Und dann gibt es vielleicht andere Menschen, die extrem gut darin sind, Bandnamen. Hier kommt unsere Website, Mixture ins Game. Mixture, wir lassen, man kann da nämlich sehr gute Bandnamen eintragen, wenn man welche hat, aber auch nur und die können gute Bands mit schlechten Bandnamen nehmen, kaufen, also ein Paket aus zehn tollen Bandnamen, man kann sich einen davon aussuchen, im Gegenzug für Songs. Du musst nämlich ein Songname, ein guter Song ist zehn Bandnamen wert. Oh, das ist so eine Art Börse oder was, wo der Kurs steigt. So, ich kann jetzt dann Song hochladen, als Band, die behauptet, einen schlechten Bandnamen zu haben, kann einen Song hochladen kostenlos, Creative Commons, der wird verkauft, nee, das ist nicht Creative Commons, an eine Band, die einen guten Bandnamen sucht. Ja, aber Songnamen ist auch eine geile Idee eigentlich, weil auch das, ich meine so als Band, du haust so.
Jetzt wird es kompliziert.
Geil, oder? Wie nennen wir den?
Burned.
Burns, Bird?
Love me crazy one more time.
The Simpsons are dead.
Don't put that in the bin. We might need it later. That's a good song. Don't put that in the bin. Do you still want to eat that? Can I eat that? Not so fast. Are you going to finish that? Not so fast. Geniale Bandname. Not so fast. Weil es einerseits so hier geblieben ist, andererseits so not so fast, not that fast. Not so fast. Not so fast, ein genialer Bandname. Und jetzt könnt ihr auf Bandnames oder Mixture, ich glaube nicht, dass es den Domainnamen noch gibt, ich glaube nicht, dass das Mixed-Sie, was nichts aussagt, aber gar nichts.
Ne, aber sowas wie Cool Names oder sowas.
Coolnames.com.
Ne, Name Trade.
Name Trade?
Ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Trade-Gedanke so gut funktioniert.
Ich glaube, man muss eher sagen, du hast einfach Listen.
Also Band Names, Song Names, Movie Names, Theme Park Names.
Und dann kannst du aber jeden Namen ... Okay, names.de.
Names, names.com.
Und dann kannst du sozusagen, wenn du aber einen Namen benutzt,
dann musst du die Seite anschreiben, hey, ich benutze den, nehm den aus der Liste.
Ja, oder aber man kann die Seite abonnieren.
Ich frage mich immer, wo machen wir dann Geld?
Ja, das ist Schritt zwei. Werbung. Das ist Schritt zwei. Ja? Ja, das ist so wie, das ist diese Mark Zuckerberg, Eduardo, äh, Zuckerberg. The best part. We are the Mark Zuckerbergs of Internet money making. Das ist ein guter Bandname. Zuckerberg. Mark Zuckerberg, kannst du direkt zu, Es ist ein wirklich guter Name. Not so fast und Mark Zuckerberg. The Zuckerbergs. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber erst mal muss die Demania groß werden. Aber gut, dass du durch Zuckerberg nicht durchgekommen bist, aber Edward Severin einfach so delivered hast, als wär's normal. Klar. Wo es ja auch hieß, ab wann soll auf Facebook Werbung sein? Und Sean Parker hat gesagt, nee, lass es erst mal gross werden und dann Werbung machen. Und jetzt haben wir genau diese Situation. Ja. Ich bin Sean Parker. Nee. Nee, du bist Eduardo Severin, ich bin Sean Parker, ich bin Justin Timberlake, du bist Andrew Garfield. Wo ist Sean, erst gute Frage. Was war Andrew Garfield? Andrew Garfield, ich habe Under the Silver Lake gesehen, ich liebe den Film, empfehle ihn aber nicht, weil ich nicht glaube, dass der vielen anderen Menschen gefällt. Aber ich fand ihn fantastisch. Weil das ist so ein richtiger, so ein schläfriger Sommerfilm. Es ist zu heiß.
So Next Level Filmkritik jetzt schon, dass es dir gar nicht mehr darum geht, einen guten Film zu promoten, wenn du nur noch an Leute denkst und vielleicht gefällt es euch nicht. Und im Megafilm schreibe ich aber nicht den Leuten keinen Tipp. Ich glaube, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen ich finde den Film gut und ich empfehle den Film. Natürlich gibt es einen Unterschied. So, und den Unterschied möchte ich dir mal klar machen. so. Ich fand den Film gut, aber wenn ihr ihn jetzt anguckt und sagt, nee, der ist ja voll langweilig. Du hast nur keinen Bock auf Males. Andrew Garfield läuft ja die ganze Zeit nur durch die Gegend und ist warm. Dann sage ich, das ist richtig, aber ich finde ihn trotzdem gut. Egal, aber toller Film. Also ich liebe Andrew Garfield, 99 Homes, fantastischer Film und The Silver Lake auch. Ich mache einen großen Andrew Andrew Garfield an. Man, Holmes ist auch ein fantastischer Titel übrigens. Ich habe, weil der nie in den Kinos war, soweit ich weiß, und dann dachte ich, vielleicht ist dann Andrew Garfield traurig. Dann habe ich ihm einen Tweet geschrieben, hey Andrew, loved you in 99 Homes. Keine Antwort, aber ich vielleicht... Weil er so traurig ist vielleicht. Vielleicht war er zu traurig, um den Tweet zu lesen. Das Problem ist, in dem Moment, in dem ich den Tweet schreibe, hat der den Film vor zwei Jahren gedreht. Das heißt, selbst wenn der ihn ärgert, dass er nicht im Film war, die Dreharbeiten sind so lange her, dass den jetzt wahrscheinlich das nicht mehr so krass trifft. Ja, genau. Jetzt gerade ist Award Season und wir haben jetzt einen Grimmelpreis bekommen für die Schaffel 1. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ja, ja. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das wollte ich nicht erwähnen. Toll, toll, toll. Weil man jetzt für etwas, das ja bei diesen Sachen auch immer, plötzlich wird man erinnert an etwas, was vor acht Jahren war. Ja. Wo ich übrigens ein bisschen traurig war jetzt, dass es das schlechteste Jahr ist, um irgendwelche Preise zu gewinnen. Und das beste Jahr, weil man, wenn man einen Preis bekommt, hat man keine Party, aber man hat auch keine langweilige Preisverleihung. Das stimmt. Und jetzt kann ich irgendwo hier im Post Office Ehrenfeld, kann ich mir dann der Grimme-Preis zugeschickt, tatsächlich. Aber hältst du deine Rede an der Parkstation? Ja, klar. Dann geht das Paket verloren. Oh nein, hat die Nachbarin das Paket. Das ist doch mein ... Hol das Paket und sei nicht zu Hause, sodass es die Nachbarin annimmt und dann, ich habe dein Paket auf dem Mann Grimmelpreis drin. Das gehört wahrscheinlich nicht mir, sondern dir, Stefan und du. Und ich sage, nee, dann sage ich so, ach, was man in dieser Corona-Zeit alles für einen Scheiss bestellt hat, ne? Hab ich gar nicht bestellt, trotzdem bekommen. Tja, so läuft es manchmal im Leben von Stefan Tietze. Und damit ... Entlassen wir euch in diese Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche. Lasst es euch gut gehen, legt euch irgendwo hin oder legt euch irgendwo drauf. Schlaft ruhig mal aus. Schlaft mal aus. Schlaft mal aus. Nehmt euch mal wirklich, macht mal die Roller zu und sagt, heute schlafe ich aus. Ich finde es auch mal geil, einfach so schön sehr früh ins Bett. Stefan, ich mag deine neue Phase nicht irgendwie, das ist, du bestehst im Kern deines Lebens, du kannst jetzt nicht den Schläfrig machen. Du kannst nicht sagen, liegt euch hin, kuschel dich ein.
Oh, das war Kuschel, damit er dann sofort ganz anders.
Das sehe ich schon.
So eine ganz grosse Bettige.
Ich bin dann wie so eine Fliege unter so einer Briefmarke.
Du kriegst auch keine Luft mehr, wie eine Fliege unter der Briefmarke.
Ich habe mich eingerollt.
Macht's gut, macht's gut, schlaf gut. Tschüss, tschüss, sagt tschüss und wir heben ab.
Zu Wolfsburg.